Well,
our topic this morning is influenza a,
which is timely for today,
and I'd like to begin by talking about
influence of virus more in general,
and we'll concentrate our
attention for obvious reasons.
On the gray,
the Spanish lady,
the great influenza of 1918
1919 no influence of virus
was isolated in the 1930s
by Andrews Wilson and Lud Law and the
mechanisms of the disease where then
unraveled. Subsequently. As you
know, there are three types,
a, B, and c, and it's a virus.
That's the cause of
pandemics among human beings.
I was terms of the structure of the virus.
As you know,
it's RNA wrapped in a protein envelope
with protein spikes on the surface.
You can see them.
Um,
and the spikes are of two major types,
Hemagglutinin and neuraminidase.
The hemagglutinin enables the virus to
attach itself to a host cell in this
case,
in the respiratory tract,
and it's neuraminidase that enables the
fusion of the virus with cells so that
the viral RNA can be released into the
cell cytoplasm and then migrate to the
cell nucleus.
The human gluten and in your amended
days have various strains that have been
numbered and you have on your handout,
um,
those that have been
identified for the 19th,
20th and 21st century and everyone
knows now a h one n one the swine virus
that's currently with us and I'm sorry
on the handout that I've got 2010,
I might to have 2009 to 2011.
So if you could make that correction,
that would make me feel happy. Uh,
the viral RNA then hijacks the cell and
transforms it into a viral factory for
the reproduction of virus and it
eventually destroys the cell itself.
This process of reproductions,
extraordinarily efficient
and nearly instantaneous so
that the idea of measuring
generations of viruses
begins to lose all meaning.
We also need to point out about,
uh,
influence influenza virus that the RNA
combines in all sorts of ways making a
genetic characteristic
of extreme instability or
should we say mutability the
processes involved that you can study
up on science hill and more detail
involved things called Antigen drift,
antigen shift,
mutation,
hybridization giving rise to subtypes,
strains,
and variants.
All of these changes are part of the
success story of influenza as a disease,
and there is no crossover immunity from
one strain to another acquired immunity.
That is his strength specific.
Well,
mutability also explains an
epidemiological feature of influenza,
and that is that pandemics
tend to arrive in waves,
each being biologically different
with different symptoms and different
virulence.
And we'll see that the great pandemic
after World War One had four major waves.
Well,
influenza tends to have be reflective of
the relationships also of human beings
and animals, birds, horses
and pigs and not theirs.
Interspecies transfer from
animals to humans and from humans.
And the reverse direction,
and this may be the route by which human
beings first contracted the disease,
and it's known that this,
the animal reservoir is
a source of new strains.
The hypothesis recently has been
that there's a reservoir in Asia,
perhaps in China or Asiatic Russia,
but interestingly,
it's not very hypothesis that
misled public health responses.
When the swine flu pandemic first got
underway and that surveillance was active
in the far east,
but the disease arrived
in stead in Mexico.
Well, what's the history of
human beings and influencer?
The origins simply aren't known.
The earliest clear evidence in of a
literary kind is in the 15th and 16th
centuries, but records are
fragmentary and unreliable.
So the best we can do is to
look at the last few centuries,
the 18th 19th 20th and the
first years of our own century.
In the 18th century,
there were major pandemics,
1729 to 30 32 to 33 61 to 62 and then
especially 1781 to 1782 and then 1788 to
1789 and the 19th century
there were pandemics.
1830 to 31 33 50 to 51 and then the
great pandemic of 1889 to 1819 and in the
20th century we've had
a number of pandemics,
the greatest sping 1918 to 20
the Spanish flu as it was called.
Now,
the reason I was reading out the rather
grim years of influenza pandemics was to
point out first,
of course,
that they're recurrent and
are still with us as you know.
But also to note that there seem to be
something of a powder and of more or less
one major pandemic and every century,
well,
influenza is a viral infection
transmitted person to person and airborne
disease,
much more contagious than say SARS that
we remember from just a few years ago.
SARS requires prolonged face to
face contact but not influenza.
So a notable feature then of the
flu is it's rapid communicability.
It also has a short incubation period,
just 24 to 72 hours.
So all of that implies also
that epidemiologically it's
different from a number
of the infectious diseases we've studied.
As I said in the email that I
sent to you about social diseases,
it's really a spectrum,
not an absolute when we talk about
being a social disease or not.
And I would submit to you that influenza
is out the far end of that spectrum in
not really being a classic social disease.
It's not very sensitive
to economic conditions,
sanitation and diet.
Those features that were hallmarks
of malaria say or tuberculosis.
It's diffusion occurs wherever human
beings move in numbers and breathe.
It follows networks of
communication where roads,
steam ships,
airplanes in our time and ports
and railroad hub cities or uh,
eh.
Now we would say airport centers tend
to be photo sigh of infection and we're
first attacked with lightening speed.
So flu was favored by the transportation
technology of the industrial revolution
and since and once again by urbanization
and of course population growth and
overcrowding.
Let's look at a precursor to the
great pandemic of the first World War.
And this is the horrible pandemic of
the 19th century of eight nine 1889 to
1890.
This was the first truly global pandemic
of influenza and the most devastating
one in history until that time
it affected every continent.
The reasons without the world was
prepared now for pandemic influenza as a
result of the transportation revolution,
the railroad on the steamship,
urbanization and trade,
demographic growth and colonialism,
vulnerability to influence or then
seems to be in part a byproduct of
modernization as we've been reminded by
recent events studies of 1889 to 1890
demonstrate this in more
detail in cities like Moscow,
Paris,
or London.
The first case is occurred in October
to November of 1889 and these tended not
to be noticed.
There was nothing particular about
them that people noted at the time,
but they occurred among very particular
sectors of the population that we're
most involved in trade commerce
and the nodes of communication.
That is the first people to fall ill
tend to to be dockers or post office
workers, railway men, policemen.
Furthermore,
the lesson dust realize the locality,
the more remote and agricultural,
it was the later,
unless severely the locality suffered
in 1889 to 1890 the Alps in Europe,
Italy,
Spain,
and Portugal all lagged behind
northern Europe and the United States.
And even in the great urban centers there
were isolated small communities that
sometimes survive entirely unscathed.
Monasteries and convents for example,
in both Moscow and Paris went experienced
the pandemic without victims in some
cases,
and this was sometimes true also of
closed institutions like prisons.
Then typically after following
the transportation network,
and this was true of 1889 to 90 the flu
spread along what's called the urban
hierarchy.
That is,
it went first to major cities and from
there into the hinterland of those cities
and only later to smaller towns,
villages and rural areas,
and 1918 to 19 in the United States shows
this same pattern that is the flu went
almost instantaneously from
Boston and New York to Cincinnati,
Chicago, New Orleans, Detroit,
San Francisco, Seattle,
and then at greater leisure.
It moved into almost every
place in between until there
was hardly a settlement
of any size that had been entirely spared.
And whenever it went rich and poor,
educated and illiterate men and women,
the physically fit and the
unfit were similarly infected,
but there were circumstances,
certain ones that were especially
favorable to the disease.
A crowded urban environment was clearly
one where people were streaming in and
out and closely packed Emilio's schools,
theaters, barracks, naval
ships, tenement buildings,
college dormitories,
and all the epidemics of influenza
except 1918 to 20 there was also a strong
predilection of the influenza virus
for the infants and the elderly.
They're also tended to be an over
representation of people with preexisting
respiratory diseases,
say tuberculosis or bronchitis or
people with immunosuppressive diseases.
The great example until the
HIV AIDS era was of course,
malaria and malarial victims were
highly susceptible to influenza,
so the tuberculosis and the malarial died
massively during influenza pandemics.
A typical graph then of the influenza,
more tality would show a neat u shaped
curve spiked at both ends of the age
spectrum of the population,
the very young and the elderly.
Another common feature of
influenza pandemics was
pronounced seasonality in the
northern hemisphere.
Influenza almost invariably
peaked in the winter months,
November to February, and ended with the
coming of warm weather in the spring.
The reasons for good epidemiological,
uh,
explanations have to do
partly with human behavior.
People tend to congregate
indoors in the winter,
often in buildings and rooms
that are poorly ventilated.
The virus itself doesn't survive well
in an environment where there's sunlight
and high humidity and winter's a time
when people tend to sneeze and cough more
than at other times.
What are some other features of flu
pandemics? One is short duration.
This helps to understand
societal responses as well.
We know that plague and collar attended
to lay siege to a locality for months
and in the community it
felt quite like that,
but flu tended to last just a
few weeks and then to move on.
It was true also that there was a high
morbidity that is lots of people would
fall ill from influenza,
but there was a low case fatality rate.
The overall mortality would be large
simply because of the large numbers of
sufferers.
The kill rate was low in the 19th century.
Influenza,
however,
killed far more people than
cholera and a stark contrast then,
um,
could be drawn.
Flew seems to be quintessentially
a contagious disease.
But since you're interested in the debate
between, this is one of your favorites,
I'm sure, uh, between anti contagion
aneurysm and contagion aneurysm,
we might point out to you that even,
although you think it seems to be
self evident that influenza the grip,
the flu is contagious,
that many of the,
in fact the dominant current still
and the 1890s was not influenza,
was not contagious.
And the eminent British epidemiologists,
Charles Creighton still held to anti
contagion ism regarding this disease down
into the 1890s well,
what sorts of things, uh,
held Creighton back from accepting
influenza as an infectious disease?
Well,
first he argued the disease would affect
the most parts of a country in the same
two or three weeks.
There simply wasn't time for a contagious
disease to a spread without extreme
rapidity.
He thought he also thought
within a smaller radius,
it seemed to affect everyone
Santa household more or less,
I'm Matine Asley everyone
would fall ill at once.
So it seemed there wasn't
time for contagion and it
was this simultaneous sudden
outbreak of influence that gave
it some of its traditional names.
It was called the grip,
not only in French log go deep,
but also in English and the 19th century.
It was referred to as grip.
And partly that's because it seems
suddenly to sees people in its grasp.
Typically,
you could be healthy at breakfast,
only defined yourself
suffering with chills, fever,
aching bones and nausea by lunchtime.
Similarly bought Moscow seem to physicians
to be healthy on the 1st of November,
1889 but by the middle of the
month the disease was everywhere.
Shops and schools were closed,
commerce nearly ground
to a halt and this gave,
it was part of the reason it
got its other name influenza.
Um,
this was an Italian word,
meaning influence and in this case people
speculated about the influence of some
cosmic factor that would
disturb the microcosm as well.
Perhaps it was the influence of the
stars or the heavens that poisoned or
corrupted the atmosphere and lay
low whole cities all at once.
Well, what about symptoms
effects on the individual?
I think we can be brief
because it's probably very
familiar to you from personal
experience.
That is seasonal influenza.
The onset is we've said
is normally sudden.
The symptoms then are ones that you know,
a high fever,
a hundred to 104 degrees Fahrenheit,
typically an unproductive cough,
aching of muscles in the back,
the legs,
watery eyes,
sometimes nausea and vomiting,
general malaise, headache,
pain in the joints,
sometimes dizziness and a general
sense of fatigue and weakness.
Typically the acute phase would last
three to five days and for a few days more
you'd suffer from your
cough and from lethargy.
And then in the vast number of
cases there would be recovery.
Well flew for young adults in good health,
enjoyed a reputation as a nasty but
mercifully short and usually not serious
affliction, influenza. And the night,
middle of the 19th century that is at
least before the cataclysm of 1889 and
1890 was people joked about it,
that it was a disease that
was so unimportant that the
only physicians who gave
it much attention were those
who simply had too few patients.
And so started treating people with flu
as a means of enhancing their income.
On the other hand,
for infants,
for the elderly and those with chronic
disease at some sometimes lead to serious
and even fatal complications.
And it was the complications much more
than the flu that tended to kill patients
who didn't recover after
three or four days,
then moved on to serious complications
like pneumonia or bronchitis and about
once a century,
a strain of influenza
that was not seasonal,
but pandemic appeared.
And demonstrated that flu can in fact
under certain conditions be one of the
most deadly of all diseases.
When the what about treatment?
Well,
today as in the past,
there's no specific remedy for influenza
as we've been reminded by recent events
in the newspapers,
the disease is self limiting
normally and simply runs its course,
so therapy is supportive and symptomatic
rest and nursing care more than active
medical intervention and the 19th century.
This was also recognized and physicians
weren't inclined to try heroic remedies
as they did say with Asiatic cholera,
but there were certain attempts at
therapeutics in the 19th century and even
after World War One,
people were given aspirin,
cinnamon with milk to
lower temperature fluids,
a nourishment bedrest,
quinine was administered
to lower the fever.
There were worn Babs for hydrotherapy.
Oxygen sometimes administered to patients
with respiratory complications and
some physicians recommended caffeine to
raise the flagging animal energy as it
was called.
Today,
the only actual
therapeutics is antibiotics,
but they don't come back
the influence itself,
but it's complication of pneumonia.
Well against that background.
Let's look more closely
at the Spanish influenza,
the Spanish lady,
the Spanish grip as it was called from
1918 to 1920 oh first you probably wonder
why the Spanish Association and the reason
has actually nothing to do with Spain
itself and disease.
It was simply that Spain was not a
belligerent and the first world war and
therefore was free of
censorship of the media.
Hence a free press reported the
medical crisis there extensively.
A popular theory in circulation these
days is that perhaps the Spanish lady
originated not in Spain at all,
but in Kansas.
In any event,
on the morning of finding the case,
zero is a perilous art,
but let's say that at least this much
as known on the morning of the 11th of
March,
1918 at Fort Riley the Cook Albert
Getchell reported sick by nearing noon.
The camp in from Marie had some 100
cases and these were the earliest known
examples of this new influenza.
There's some background that helps us
comprehend the extraordinary case of 1918
to 1920 as in the past mutations occurred
and then this time produced a new
strain that turned out to me more
virulent than any in influences history.
It's mode of communication was
identical to other flu pandemics,
but its effects on both the individual
and society were radically different.
So let's talk about this
pandemic as coming in for waves.
The first was in the spring of 1918 and
was relatively mild in March and April.
It soon passed under an
attracted little attention.
Wartime press.
Censorship was partly a factor,
but people were simply
preoccupied with the war, uh,
not with the presence of a mild outbreak
of a well known and common disease.
The second wave was the of 1918
which was the worldwide disaster.
It began in August with
simultaneous explosions in
places as far apart as Sierra
Leon, Boston and this
country, breast and France.
A common feature being that these were
all port cities and had an important role
in the movements of troops and supplies.
In this case,
one could argue that
not only the war itself,
but also the coming of peace contributed
to the spread of the flu armistice day
itself produce huge crowds and gatherings,
uh,
which were not propitious for
stopping the spread of the disease.
Then came the spring of 1919, uh, less,
much less mercifully less severe wave.
And then finally,
January,
February of 1920 the fourth
wave of this Spanish lady,
which was mild and limited and it's
morbidity even partly of course,
because by then so many people were
already immune where there are a number of
features of this Spanish
lady that made her unique.
The first was not possessed,
an extraordinary mortality and morbidity.
Comparing it with normal
outbreaks of influenza.
It's impossible to generate
precise statistics,
but there are speculations that
this was perhaps in absolute terms,
the greatest demographic shock that
humanity had ever experienced from
infectious diseases.
The more people died of influenza than
of casualties in the first world war
worldwide. Some estimates,
the estimates vary widely,
so one has to take them
with great caution,
but they range from 25 million people
perishing upwards to the highest estimates
or about 100 million in the United States.
It's pretty well known that at least
675,000 people perished more than American
casualties and all 20th century wars,
10 times the numbers killed in
first world war and a normal,
if there is such a thing,
influenza outbreak,
a case fatality rate might be something
like oh 0.1% in the case of the Spanish
influenza,
the case fatality rate was just above
2.5% and this yielded a vast total bull
mortality because indeed
as it seemed at the time,
almost everyone was infected.
Let's look at a slide of the death rates.
You can see the influenza,
the great wave,
and October,
November,
December of 1918 the black is 1918,
uh, rather, sorry, a 1911 as the average,
1911 to 1917 and the gray is 1918.
So this compares,
uh,
influenza then with what we
might call normal influenza.
You can see the
extraordinary near mortality.
Another feature of this influenza was
the lack of understanding of the disease
when it broke out.
Indeed.
I'd like to quote Viktor
Vaughn who directed public
health in the United States
army against the Spanish lady and he said,
and I'm quoting doctors,
no,
no more about the flu.
Then 14th century Florentines did
about the black death and I think it's
important to understand this idea of a
sense of helplessness facing this medical
catastrophe.
Some physicians indeed in 1918
termed what they were facing,
epidemic pneumonia and then as now
there was no effective treatment.
The symptoms were distinctive.
As you now know from reading Cosby,
this influenza was fulminant
and post Wharton mortem.
Long examinations
revealed things that were unlike anything
that examining physicians had seen
before.
Enormous quantities of bloody fluid,
like a froth filling the lungs.
Some physicians on their first encounter
suspected that this was a kind of
pneumonic plague
right here in new haven and the new
haven hospital pathologists wrote the
devastation caused to the lungs more than
anything else resembled the effects of
poisonous gases used in world war
one like phosgene or chlorine,
whether comparisons that came
to their mind. Furthermore,
although other organs of the body
could be effected the spleen,
for example,
the impact of the Spanish lady on the
lungs was so overwhelming that not alone
was often the cause of
death and pulmonary effects.
We're almost the only
ones that people noticed.
Let me read a passage from
Katherine Anne Porter,
the famous writer, Pale Horse, Pale rider,
um,
where she was herself a
victim of the influencer.
And she writes here in the third person,
but she's describing her own symptoms and
I think it's worth noting how she felt
silenced.
Miranda's sank easily through deep sip
on deeps of darkness until she lay like a
stone at the farthest bottom of
life knowing herself to be blind,
deaf,
speechless.
No longer aware of the
members of her own body,
entirely withdrawn from
all human concerns,
yet alive with the peculiar
lucidity and coherence,
all notions of the mind,
the reasonable inquiries of doubt,
all ties of blood and desires of the
heart dissolved and fell away from her and
there remained only a minute,
fiercely burning particle of being
that new itself alone that relied upon
nothing beyond itself for its strength,
not susceptible to any
appeal or inducement being
itself composed entirely of
one single motive.
The stubborn will to live this fiery,
motionless particle set itself
unaided to resist destruction,
to survive and to be in its own madness
of being motiveless and plan lists.
Beyond that one essential end,
she felt without warning a
vague tremor of apprehension,
some small flick of distrust and her joy,
a thin frost touch the edges
of this confident tranquility.
Something somebody was missing,
she'd lost something she had left,
something valuable than another country.
What could it be?
There are no trees, no trees
here. She said in fright,
I've left something unfinished.
A thought struggled at the back of her
mind came clearly as a voice in your ear
where the dead, we've forgotten the
dead, the dead. Where are they at?
Once as if a curtain had fallen,
the bright landscape faded.
She was alone in a strange
stony place of bitter cold,
picking her way along the
steep path of slippery snow.
Calling out, oh, I must go
back, but in what direction?
Pain returned.
A terrible,
compelling pain running through
our veins like heavy fire,
the stench of corruption
filled her nostrils,
the Swedish sickening smell
of rotting flesh and pos.
She opened her eyes and saw
appeal light through course,
white cloth over her face and she knew
that the smell of death was in her own
body and she struggled to lift her hand.
There are also pictures of um,
this is a famous painting of Ed Voir monk
after the influence in 1919 or this is
also in fact,
this is called after
the flu painted in 1919.
A doctor wrote that his patients died
struggling to clear their airways of a
blood tinge froth that gushed
from their noses and mouths.
The fluid then filled the respiratory
system from the trachea to the tiniest Avo
lay and bronchioles and it
post mortem examination.
The lungs were greatly acts distended
and when pressed even lightly oozed with
blood tinge,
fluid and yellow pus.
The walls of the Avo lie collapsed under
the pressure leaving the formless mass
where neither blood nor air could flow
freely and the patient died of his fix
sia or the blockage of
pulmonary circulation.
Let me show you two pictures of the
lungs of a young woman who died of the
Spanish lady at the new haven hospital.
Um,
and I think you can see the enormous
and terrifying destruction of the lungs
that occurred.
Well in addition,
there were important sequoia.
One feature of this Spanish lady was the
distinctive length of convalescence and
also there were neurological aftereffects,
protracted depression.
And there is speculation that throughout
the 1920s there was an outbreak of
neurological afflictions that Oliver
Sacks deals with and his famous book
awakenings.
There's some dispute about whether this
was an authentic amongst the authentic
Kweli of the Spanish influenza,
but it is at least plausible.
Another feature that made this pandemic
distinctive was the age profile of the
victims.
We've seen how normally an
influenza Thursday u shaped curve,
it does what seems normal to people
attacking the very young and the elderly.
The Spanish lady instead had a preference
for adults and the 20 to 40 age group
and so it produced something
that seemed highly unnatural,
a w shaped curve with a spike in the
middle afflicting the people in the prime
of life.
Viktor Vaughn again observed that the
Spanish flu imitated the war itself and
then it killed young adults like war.
He said this infection kills young,
vigorous,
robust adults.
The reasons are still mysterious,
but one could point to a
couple of partial factors.
Perhaps the elderly had some immunity
leftover from the great pandemic of 1889
to 19 and it was the young of course,
epidemiologically who most
directly experienced the
war and military service and
close crowded conditions,
just the young population most at risk.
And for those of you who think that
working out at the gym protects you from
influenza pandemics,
I would point out that the physically
fit also fell ill in comparable numbers.
John Hellem,
the u s pentathlon champion,
that is someone who did the broad jump
discuss Java Olin 200 meters and 1500
meters died in October of 1918 of the
flu as did Jackie O'shaughnessy who was
the u s national quarter mile champion.
So physical fitness had nothing to
do with survival from the influencer.
Let me show you a graph.
This is the notorious u shape curve of
the influenza and you see the two curves
together.
The dotted line is normal influencer and
this solid line with the terrible w in
the middle is the more
comedy from the Spanish lady.
Well meanwhile,
what happened with public health and
here a major feature is to point out,
and we should think of this in terms of
lessons for preparedness today was the
way that the public health
service was overwhelmed.
It was overwhelmed and part because of
the extreme rapidity with which this
disease through it's airborne
transmission was spread
by the speed of transportation and the
short incubation period of the disease
too is also true that
there is a percentage,
perhaps 10% in the Spanish lady of
people who are asymptomatic carriers.
Influenza also was not
a reportable disease.
It was maximized also because of the
unavoidable and uncontrollable movement of
troops because of the war.
But in addition there was a lock and we
might think about this of preparation
for just such an emergency,
a shortage of doctors,
nurses,
hospital beds and space
one hospital wards.
Influenza also has the terrible feature,
unlike cholera for example,
that it creates chaos within the
health system itself by striking down
caregivers who are among
those who are most vulnerable.
And then there was the war itself in
which doctors and nurses were mobilized to
deal with the victims of the conflict.
So there were a drastic shortages of
healthcare personnel available to the
civilian population.
Roofer glue,
whom you will remember from the Barbary
Plagge who was the director of public
health services during the crisis.
And he was forced to lure doctors and
nurses out of retirement to help deal with
the emergency,
to recruit even from old age homes.
Well,
what were the measures adopted
to deal with the crisis?
Antiflu measures by this time were
based on the premise that this was a
contagious disease and the understanding
that influenza was spread somehow
through the air.
So our first major goal was to prevent
those who are healthy from inhaling the
contaminated air of the infected.
So in that,
and to that end,
public gatherings and assemblies of
large numbers of people at close quarters
were banned.
Public institutions were closed,
schools, dance halls,
movie theaters, bars,
churches in this country
were allowed to remain open,
but the number of services
was greatly reduced.
And many cities,
people seen by the police to be coughing
and sneezing without covering their
faces were stopped and find.
The New York City Department of Health
posted some 10,000 plaque cards around
the city bearing a message that was
familiar to the public because of its
similarity to the urgings of the
campaign against tuberculosis.
So one can see the anti-tuberculosis
campaign preparing people in a sense for
dealing with influenza
and in New York City,
the placards said to prevent
the spread of Spanish influenza,
sniff costs or expect to
rate if you absolutely must
into your own handkerchief.
You're no, no danger if everyone
should heed this warning.
Another widespread measure was
a of practical application.
Also one was masking with gauze masks
and some municipalities require their
whole populations to put on masks.
San Francisco did so and so did San Diego.
Another was disinfection practices
applied in hospital wards,
sick rooms and ambulances.
Trains too were washed down
with antiseptic solutions.
You can see a picture
of the properly mass,
uh, police, I think this
is San Francisco. Um,
wind here you can see the general
mass gain of the whole population.
And this was a public notice of
public health poster from Kingston,
New York or,
yeah.
Oh and it says about the measures I've
told you about theaters, churches,
schools, hospitals and so forth. Or um,
you can see here another
poster for public health. Well,
state boards of health also isolated.
The ill through quarantine
are as far as possible.
And the military tried to quarantine
it's training camps on hospital wards.
Sheets were hung between beds.
Ambulance trains were
washed down with antiseptic.
People were urge to avoid
nervous and physical exhaustion.
You can see a long legacy of this idea.
You remember Lynette talking
about the posse on Triste,
the sad, um, uh,
passions and their influence
on your constitution. So these,
some of the advice had a really
long history that you'll recognize.
And he also, they also cautioned
you are to avoid chills.
They urged people to gargle with warm
water and salt and just spray say line
solutions up their nose to where gauze
masks and legislation was passed to
prevent the use of common drinking cops.
Some people sprayed their nostrils with
carbolic acid spray and some towns set
up fines to punish people.
They called.
This was one of the jargons at the time.
The open face sneezer well,
New York City modified the opening hours
of stores and businesses in order to
stagger rush hour so that subway trains
and trems would not be so crowded and
not be so dangerous.
Congress voted special funds to an agent,
able as surgeon general Rupert blue to
recruit thousands of doctors and hundreds
of nurses.
But as I said,
the war effort complicated his task
and he turned to people who'd retired.
Um, those were other, I
wanted to show you, um,
a camp,
a fact that it was wartime,
made it easy for the government to induce
people to accept rigorous measures.
People by this time had grown use by 1918
too invasive and restrictive measures.
They already knew all about the draft
or rationing or daylight savings time,
but existing facilities were
inadequate to cope with a sudden surge.
And so the general public
one can see, um, uh,
suffering as a result of that.
And I wanted to mention that there
were also popular remedies that people
adopted and especially in rural areas,
recourse to folk remedies and magic onion
soup was thought to be a preventative
people stuff salt up their
nostrils to ward off danger.
They wore garlic around their neck as
they had in Florence and the time of Boob
onic plague.
They burned heart charcoals with
sulfur or brown sugar to give off for
reassuring protective aroma.
You can recognize this
too from the plague.
There were rumors that the disease
perhaps was inactive bioterror.
There were thoughts that there were
mysterious German agents who landed on new
boats and started the epidemic.
There were suspicions to that poisonous
gasses associated with the war effort
had escaped and caused the disaster.
Well,
I will run out of time now and just say
that one of the things to think about
then or what,
or possible lessons,
and I just wanted to leave us to think
as we deal with our own h one n one and
possibly whatever its successor is
that clearly in 1918 and 19 there's a
collective memory in the public health
service of the vulnerability of a society
of critically ill patients turn away
from hospitals that were full to bursting
with no care available because
the system was overwhelmed.
And there's a fear then of what about the
effects now of the impact of organized
care medicine on a managed
care basis with cutting costs,
cutting search for savings in our system.
The commitment to reading hospitals
have excess capacity and spare beds.
And so this approach raises the question
of what would happen and another time
when the system might
once again be tested.